des diables chargé des dizaines de fois
pour remplir le camion à versailles ce
vendredi 11 mars les employés de la
mairie charge les dizaines de dons
collectés par les maisons de quartiers
de la ville nous avons revu prévu que
deux camionnettes de ville de versailles
partent mardi les iron donc sur un point
de dispatching qui se trouve à la
frontière polonaise et ensuite ce sont
des camions qui viennent d'ukraine qui
récupère donc ces différents dons et qui
les emmène là où c'est utile jean
clément sera l'un des chauffeurs
volontaires pour amener tous ces dons
c'est en apportant moi j'aime bien aider
les gens en difficulté
ça me permet de voir un petit peu aussi
les aider de ramener de fournitures de
tout ça une collecte organisée avec
l'association école ukrainienne de
paris-saint volodymyr une association
qui donne depuis vingt ans des cours à
de jeunes ukrainiens arrivée en france
je fais un appel la ville de versailles
qui est très généreuse et je veux
remercier du fond du coeur pour tous que
les versaillais
nous apporte aujourd'hui les camions qui
trouve versailles ce mardi 15 mars à 5
heures du matin 1800 km à parcourir pour
atteindre leur destination